today's episode is brought to you by
America's best unlimited network don't
miss a show with unlimited data from
t-mobile
hello screen junkies I'm so excited to
do another special honest trailer
commentary we will be watching The Lion
King on his trailer with the director
himself mr. Rob Minkoff welcome Rob
thank you very nervous are you excited
I've seen it before I've heard I have
seen it yeah if I you know and of course
I loved it because I'm here I'm Andy
signor Dan Merle Spencer Gilbert the
honest trailers crew that we did this
home a long time ago when everyone asks
what's your favorite this is always one
of the ones I pull to do you guys agree
ya know the music and everything and I
think this was this our first Disney I
think it might have been frozen was
we're very excited because tomorrow the
Lion King comes out remastered in the
special Signature Collection blu-ray
digital combo pack you can pick it up in
stores go support if you don't already
have it go get it again
I hear it's got a whole bunch of cool
new special features and things yes yes
it does it shows too behind the scenes
making of the movie me and Roger Allers
pitching board singing Hakuna Matata oh
yeah how much jtt does it have in it
we're gonna watch in a second with you
but I'm just curious do you remember
seeing it or any thoughts of going in
I'd like to get a blind reaction first
oh I'll go trailer yeah did you remember
anything particular oh wow yes honest
trailers are amazing it's actually I
think I'd rather see honest trailers
than regular trailers because they
really they tell you what you need to
know right they tell you everything
there is to be told so I know I'm Finn
thank you that's very cool how cool is
that
man I'll tell you Matata all right well
let's get to it let's watch it now the
way this works is we will pause if we
want to ask you something if you would
like to challenge us or make a comment
you can pause it make sense yeah let's
do it
a lot of comments before they was frozen
relive the peak of Disney animation
followed immediately by its downfall The
Lion King revisit the original tale the
royal heir whose parents died prompting
them to run away from their Kingdom then
sing a song about letting go of their
worries while things fall apart back
home and return to defeat an evil Prince
I knew there was a reason I liked that
movie pause what you said already was
that you had already frozen may have
been the first movie you did frozen an
Lion King because you know it's a double
feature no I it's obviously it's up I
mean it that's a call but that's a
backhanded compliment sure so it's not
really a criticism my farm oh no it's
just straight out calling out frozen and
I know the guy sent me frozen too so
they're old friends of mine
so did well they're doing fine things
maybe you know they actually did all
right need a bride Rock and animal
kingdom with some incredibly generous
boarders everything the light touches is
our kingdom and its own version of New
Jersey what about that shadowy place
let's never go this question please why
does New Jersey have such a bad rap it's
not so bad
well parts are night I lived a group of
Philadelphia so I guess I had a little
bit of like anti Jersey Philly they
called the Garden State
yeah there's there are pockets that are
wonderful there's a nice short áown have
I've seen the Jersey Shore well I've
yeah well yeah I mean that's the show
yeah yeah yeah but the line looks like
mr. Jenner is what happened to Snooki
she still she was on Celebrity why not
tell me pub the generous borders though
is that it does
were there any actual Ryan wall you were
researching yeah it's a very ancient
lion lion law it was kind of a night the
metaphor mikake like we have everything
belongs to them but the Lions allowed
mean the lion is the king
yeah well that you know the thing the
thing was is that there was no people
right cuz it's we we often talked about
that we like our people to people exist
to this movie take place before
civilization before humanity possibly
didn't yeah that's what's your stance
you think possibly I think possibly yeah
this is before humankind I think before
yeah okay so pre jungles no no no mine
here in film and your mind is connected
in this universe
no okay okay Lion King one-and-a-half is
that connected tangentially look the
only thing connecting it to other Disney
movies is like the restroom it's
reinforcing monarchy is a legitimate
form of government
exactly which I think in the world we're
in its may be a reasonable to be made
for that that's true let's keep watching
evil British it's to die Latino que pasa
Jewish mom's
where you from gangster or CNN
when I do it several times
Jewish mugs confused mom what that was
actually you know that was such a funny
thing because you know you wouldn't
expect necessarily people speaking you
know with that kind of an accent on the
Savannah but it worked you know it was
funny made it fun made it fun what's it
like working with James Earl Jones I
mean that the question has to be amazed
do you make him say funny things my son
and the one true king
remember - Lee did I did I have to do we
actually recorded our voices doing
scratch and I did I did Mufasa before
James Earl Jones did and we came into
our session and I had done a line and we
put a little reverb on it said it's a
pretty good you got to do it and he was
like well what's wrong with what's wrong
with that it's gotta be you know that's
like directed I resemble that what's the
call when you fix in the ADR did all the
scratch I'd be proud of that all right
let's keep watching
EMBO and obnoxious know-it-all who rubs
his privilege in everyone's face
watches Simba's life of leisure is
shattered by his evil uncle a lion who
was either named scar by coincidence
already got stuck with a really mean
nickname you know I think it was a
really mean nickname but pretty much I
mean you know we sort of we always
thought that you know Mufasa probably
was the one who did it you know they
were playing around they were just kids
but Mufasa took it a little too far and
then you know just call him that you
know he thought it was kind of endearing
and you know nice and what do you think
his real name would have been that's
some real Lion King facts here yeah was
canon now there was some canonical thing
in a sequel or team so it was I mean I
think there was there wasn't it yeah but
you know it was only 23 years ago that
we need them we had Frank I mean that's
so mean it's like if fossa had like
injured his leg or something that was
just a coincidence Wow yeah we're ironic
don't you think I think it'd only be
irony if his name was Captain hand was
made of iron so g-rated movie filled
with domestic abuse I'm a child raised
by same-sex couple not that there's a
problem that and the most traumatic
death of a parent since baby's mom got
shot in the face now a lot of us this
was our Bambi yeah do you want to
apologize well you know what actually
it's a funny you know Randy Newman Oh
I've met him several times he doesn't he
doesn't actually know my name but he
calls me the guy that killed Mufasa says
you're the guy where's there like but
how do you Det how do you balance that
you just because I applaud it for its
realness like I almost have glad I show
my kid this cuz it almost is a way to
introduce that that's that's actually
you know but actually knowing we
finished the movie that's what we talked
about the fact that people could you
know families could actually approach
the subject in a way that was good which
is different than ban because if you
recall that she gets shot and then you
never see her again never so there was
no there was no closure and there is
with this you know I mean even though
he's you know trying to bring his dead
father back to life which is very sad
you know he's it's it's actually there
he's real and and and there were people
at the time who didn't think it was you
know appropriate for us to do that
wanted us to put him back in the shadows
you know make it very sort of yeah was
your was it what there was there a
darker version or is it his darkest well
I think there's just the idea that he
would actually go up and and you know
but it's very real
I don't know it was I think also for
animation you want to kind of go a
little further than what's been done
before so do you think that bringing him
not back but having him come back as
kind of a spirit guide helps undoubtedly
I think that that's actually the most
important thing because you know he says
Mufasa actually tells Simba if you you
know your ping dechen what about the
stars and the kings of the past looked
down on us from those stars and he says
he doesn't actually say I will always he
says I'll always be with you but I'll be
with you and the stars so he's sort of
trying to very subtly hmm you know let
him know that things are gonna happen
that she's the circle of life but I
think when he comes back as a as a
spirit and was interesting because I
took my son was five years old he's
actually not even five he's is gonna be
five in a week and a half I took him
last week to the El Capitan in Hollywood
to see the movie projected on the big
screen time first time never seen moving
and and he turned to me when Mufasa is
ghost was coming back and ghost daddy is
that his spirit like wow oh my god where
did you pick that up front
I have a final - it's so weird now they
pick it all up now the movies help
strangely gay things or some of those
things and learn it yeah do you feel
like Pixar's trying to one-up that that
blanking death in their movies now with
up and finding Nemo I feel like they
just constantly just kill making us
thinking set it up for like now it's
sort of like that Disney staple a thing
yeah what Disney always said there was
always a thing about losing a parent you
know there's sometimes it was usually
there was never there was always one
parent you know there was always a
missing father mother so there was
always something to resolve something
frozen or Rapunzel or okay both parents
sometimes oh yeah I always wonder all
right let's keep going
so that grows and go and experience the
best music of any Disney musical ever at
Witts incredible songs like they'll be
careful what you wish for song yes
they're plotting evil stuff song because
for me to do bad guy
not your least favorite one let's be
prepared do you prepare I mean I look
they're all amazing but if you had to
pick out your favorite kid in the
soundtrack yeah I wouldn't that would
not be the number one but we got to do
some interesting things I don't know if
you you know knows but there's one
moment where the hyenas ever you know oh
yeah that's when I was a kid yeah
terrified me like when I saw that was
like yeah don't just you know just
wanted to go there and say that yes
they're bad no pushback they're bad no
yeah well a little bit
this is hotly debated because we didn't
Little Mermaid we even went a little
further was Ursula song and said like
hey you can skip that one because there
are some people that are like yeah you
know the bad guys some people like know
the bad guys songs are my favorites sure
sure sure I actually worked on that in
Little Mermaid because they designed
Ursula oh wow she worked on the song - I
did and I brought in an a friend who was
an actor that I knew from CalArts where
I went to school to dress in dress up so
he was a man dressed as a woman which
was kind of the whole Gestalt of the
character that's it kind of a drag queen
and then we we actually filmed his
performance doing doing a poor
unfortunate soul yeah that song is all
about the performance is such a
wonderful performance yeah I do like
that song alright let's see what else we
son to distract kids from the horrific
death that you saw
[Music]
forget all that an African catchphrase
that was actually no that was this not
the first version of the song there was
another song and then this was written
afterwards because you know because we
had that African cash fringe we had to
get some good that nobody knew and
what's so crazy is that since the movie
came out everybody everybody knows what
that means you can't go anywhere in the
world without somebody knowing lacunae
Matano yeah and in fact I just saw this
great thing from the the stark sisters
from Game of Thrones yeah big fan and
they do it this sort of funny take on
Hakuna Matata as I was in the carpool
karaoke really fun now is she playing
the finale in my head I was like they
were great last night by the way anyway
there's no spoilers here let's see what
was next the slow jam
[Music]
yeah we are totally gonna bore
dumi ice that has become a meme yeah
it's so funny because again you know
when we did the song the first time we
actually tried to do something that was
really not a love song so we had to
moana pupas sing the whole song and it
is sort of a comedy send up and then we
played it for Elton and he hated it he
was like what have you done my song so
we ran back to Glendale swear to God and
we we had to redo the whole thing and
then we you know we strike cuz that one
said one of the reasons he did the movie
was to write a great Disney romantic
ballad so we're like okay we're gonna go
for it and we're gonna do the do me eyes
they're great
yeah but this this was there was never a
thought of too sexy you know she
actually in the next scene she I she
licks him yeah you know
Prince Hans or ever licks Elsa so
weirdly true they're just animals sorry
and the song that fools us into thinking
these animals live in harmony
[Music]
maybe by major props for the layer yeah
this is actually true though
[Music]
reminder
we got opposers they got some singers
who did the Broadway live it's fantastic
and actually it's an amazing story
because Lemmo who came in to hans zimmer
studio and actually wrote those swahili
words and sang at you know was just kind
of amazing because he came in we was he
didn't know anything about the movie and
we explained them the story and we said
well you know we need want this chanting
thing happening here and then he walked
away because I can't help but sing along
and Google can be wrong and if Google
says something different than Google's
wrong yeah yeah we got together you said
it the pronounced way if I'm wrong
though people are gonna write to me
we're gonna what have you done to our
language let's keep going worth are
starring normals their hurry why in
Jafar
bird Sebastian reading snippy ed Edd and
Eddy do me eyes
we had fader and Kimba the White Lion
seriously look it up the lion I gotta go
no there was a no-no so so no it came up
in a big way and we were like it was not
it was the collective unconscious I
think it was somehow happily where we
were but there were more than a few
similarities which of course was
shocking and frightening but but it was
as as far as I know I did was not even
know how to do it yeah yeah no yeah I
didn't know but sometimes Shakespeare or
only wrote like four plays that were all
dis copying over and over again I feel
like it's impossible to not accidentally
people it happens it's the universal
lines we have one more gay guy when you
talk about oh yeah wait if Mufasa and
scar the only male lions in the pride
the knowledge dad is probably oh no
unfortunately probably true no we got
into trouble in fact it was got it got
printed recently that that we said that
this guard Mufasa we're not brothers but
they are they I just want to clear that
up just in case that hit your radar is
they would typically be in different
prides typically in different prides but
you know I but for sure they grew up
together as we said you know you know
how did he get that scar scar was
crashing on the fauces couch for a long
time yeah he seems like that type you
have to cut the couch crasher yeah for
sure yeah any final questions for him
guys that you can think of that was so
much fun thank you for doing it I mean
what's your now with the movies it
constantly always coming back I mean
what is it that just must be amazing to
I mean be part of this movie I you know
it is hard to believe that it's just key
seems to keep going on and on what's
your favorite takeaway like when you go
back and think about it like is there
one story you can share like you'll
never forget that that moment of in the
making of it well you know I think for
us because when we were making the movie
before it actually was finished
nobody kind of knew what it was so we
were following along a little mermaid
beating the beast and Aladdin which were
huge hit a lot of pressure a lot of
pressure and people didn't know when we
said it's called The Lion King there
what's that and in fact I remember
pitching it to a friend of mine and that
after I was done he said you know what's
a call I said The Lion King coos oh
that's a terrible time worked in many
different facets across the whole media
of Broadway everything a dip were you
involved in the Broadway at all I mean
no not directly of course yeah yeah yeah
was there we were going to the premiere
as a matter of fact and that was 20
years ago Wow yes still get there gonna
do a big 20-year reunion and there and
now John Ferraro is bringing this back I
mean do you want to share any thoughts
on that have you talked to him I have we
actually had lunch and then he invited
me to come to the studio and I got to
put on the VR goggles and fly around
Pride Rock which was very cool I hope
everybody gets a chance to do that
because it's awesome yeah yeah very
exciting and I know they played the
circle of life at the d23 Convention I
didn't get to see it but I heard people
loved it so what is your feeling I mean
like if you could go back do you still
like no it has to be an impact what's
your thought on this sort of live action
animation world I mean if you had the
technology today when you were back then
would you have chosen to try that way
I'm curious it's interesting I you know
they're really two different you know
forms so you know in our you know
animated version obviously the
characters come to life in a different
way they've obviously performed they're
more like people in a way so I think in
a live-action kind of mode which of
course will be done you know with
technology
they'll look more realistic so they
won't you know have the same expressions
but I think it'll probably be more real
in a way so at the Stampede mufasa's
death
you know already preparing my unborn
child actually what are things John said
to me he said you know if we made this
movie today for the first time he said
we never could have killed Mufasa in the
middle of the movie you know you can
kill a parent at the beginning in the
first and kill them yet come on you can
only kill imaginary friends
anything exciting you're working on next
you can talk about yeah a couple
different things I'm working on a new
animated movie called wolf totem which
is about sex about wolves in Mongolia oh
great and they everyone can pick up
Signature Collection on blu-ray digital
combo today tomorrow a Tuesday in stores
to check it out thank you so much for
coming rob this was so much fun to do it
and I appreciate you humoring us and
letting us play with your classic movie
that honestly defined I think each of us
I done pretty much it really did like
was a crucial movie in my childhood to
sort of really learn about filmmaking
and just animation and so Bravo sir
thank you thank you thank you and thank
you for a great honest trailer thank you
and thank you all for watching we'll be
back hopefully with another fabulous who
else wants to come in and watch their
movie he did it you guys can go to very
grateful to rob check out the blu-ray
combo pack in stores and thank you so
much - see you next time bye bye thanks
again to t-mobile for sponsoring today's
episode check out what makes them
America's best unlimited network at
t-mobile comm slash coverage
you